bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec à nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce mercredi 11 novembre
deuxième semaine de confinement en
france et premier point d'étape sur la
situation sanitaire prise de parole
attendue de jean castex demain à 18
heures après un conseil de défense un
assouplissement des règles de
confinement ne semble pas privilégiée
malgré un frémissement selon les mots
d'olivier ferrand les commerces dinh
dung essentielles n'ont qu'une seule
idée en tête rouvrir le plus vite
possible à la poche des fêtes de noël
aux états unis la séquence past
élections toujours enlisé et joe biden
est là sur l'attitude de donald trump
n'aura pas d'impact sur le transfert du
pouvoir mais pour admire à l'héritage
politique un des républicains donnaient
leur appui refuse toujours de concéder
sa défaite à la présidentielle
même position pour son secrétaire d'état
ump aux la transition s'annonce
compliqué les relations entre israël et
les états unis elle est au beau fixe
donald trump et miami netanyahu
affichent leur proximité depuis quatre
ans le premier ministre aura attendu
dimanche matin pour saluer joe biden en
évoquant je cite leur longue et
chaleureuse relations depuis près de 40
ans mais est ce vraiment une bonne
nouvelle pour celui qui avait donc nouer
un lien très fort avec donald trump
sommes nous irons à tel aviv retrouver
notre correspondante sur place
[Musique]
bientôt quinze jours de confinement le
premier ministre jean castex prendra la
parole demain à 18 heures pour une
conférence de presse sur la situation
sanitaire et les mesures de restriction
un point d'état comme la premier manuel
macron lors de son allocution du 28
octobre
il fera suite à un conseil de défense
plus tôt dans la matinée
alors quelle orientation pourrait
prendre le gouvernement ont fait le
point avec solène goda et lucas tu as
plusieurs scénarios sont envisagés
première option un durcissement des
mesures sanitaires dans certains
secteurs
jean michel blanquer ministre de
l'éducation nationale sera présent à
cette conférence de presse et sa
présence laisse penser qu'il tentera de
répondre aux attentes des enseignants et
des parents d'élèves
et selon les informations de nos
confrères de rmc la fermeture des lycées
pourraient être annoncés ce jeudi
deuxième possibilité un assouplissement
des mesures pour les commerces dits non
essentiel en tout cas c'est ce qu'il
réclame et avec l'appui du patronat
geoffroy roux de bézieux le président du
medef tire la sonnette d'alarmé dans une
interview au monde
selon lui il est inenvisageable de
laisser les commerces fermés al'approche
des fêtes de fin d'année alors vous
l'aurez compris de nombreux français
attendent le gouvernement au tournant
nous sommes allé leur demander quelles
sont leurs attentes bon on espère bien
sûr un assouplissement mais un peu de
mal à y croire avant les fêtes je pense
que ça durera au delà janvier j'espère
qu'on pourra rebuter les fêtes de noël
avec nos familles peut-être pas le
nouvel an parce que c'est vrai que sarko
fin il ya beaucoup de gens au nouvel an
c'est plus une soirée mais au moins un
mois de noël j'aurais bien aimé voir mes
grands parents
je pense que le comment dirais-je les
décisions là de faire un confinement un
peu demi comme ça
c'est c'est assez bâtards parce que
finalement on a tous les inconvénients
d'un confinement n'est quand même
vachement limités dans nos liberté de
déplacement etc et pour autant je suis
pas certaine après moi je souhaite que
ça le fasse mais je suis pas certaine
que ça casse le truc je pense que ça ne
peut pas être plus dur que maintenant je
pense que là on est au bout du rouleau
alors qu'est-ce qui va voir contre
durcissement j'en sais rien c'est tout
le monde continue à la maison hélas la
csn a fait un peu plus un peu plus
rependu supporté voilà
mais la situation sanitaire reste
préoccupante le pic de l'épidémie est
attendu pour ce week end selon jérôme
salomon le directeur général de la santé
le gouvernement pourrait donc faire le
choix d'un statu quo c'est-à-dire
prolonger le confinement dans les
conditions actuelles
avec en ligne de mire sauver les fêtes
de fin d'année mais selon les propres
mots du ministre de la santé olivier
verront noël ne sera pas une fait normal
cette année et quelles que soient les
mesures annoncées demain les commerçants
artisans et commerces dits non
essentielles n'ont qu'une seule idée en
tête rouvrir au plus vite à la proche
des fêtes de noël une question de survie
pour beaucoup d'entre eux seule
concession jusqu'ici la livraison et le
retrait des commandes qui reste permis
dans l'ensemble de ses magasins place à
notre décryptage avec nos invités
[Musique]
mais pour en parler nous sommes avec
franck mathais directeur commercial du
magasin la grande récré olivier marc et
aux restaurateurs qui est le patron du
bistrot musique dans le 19e
arrondissement de paris
enfin d'elazig boumédiène président de
l'association des commerçants
indépendants des marchés bonsoir à tous
les trois merci messieurs d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france donc ça
fait quinze jours bientôt un que vous
êtes fermer à nouveau le tout dans une
période évidemment cruciale à deux mois
de noël les français font
traditionnellement leurs courses de
fêtes de fin d'année le ministre chargé
des relations avec le parlement et
cartes une réouverture des commerces non
essentiels à ce stade vous êtes inquiet
quel est votre état d'esprit vous par
exemple franck m'étais grande
spécialiste évidemment des jouets oui
juste précisé qu' aujourd'hui je
représente tous joué club je suis le
porte parole national de joué club et
tout ça pour dire qu'effectivement les
magasins de jouets sont aujourd'hui des
magasins est essentielle parce que
chaque français est en train de préparer
sa peine de noël les enfants ont
commandé leur jouer au père noël et le
rôle des parents aujourd'hui c'est de
faire en sorte que cette liste elles
puissent être servis
le 25 décembre au pied des sapins donc
il est évident que plus on attend la
réouverture des magasins de jouets et
plus la concentration des clients
risquent d'être forte
parce que pour nos clients et bien 40%
des demandes se font sur le mois de
novembre et 60% des ventes se font sur
le mois de décembre
donc si on rapatrie toutes les ventes du
mois de novembre sur le mois de décembre
sera créé les embouteillages dans les
magasins le click and collect
aujourd'hui n'est pas la solution que
les clients privilégient et quand bien
même si demain il n'y avait que le click
and collect et bien les systèmes ne sont
pas suffisamment costaud pour pouvoir
satisfaire tout ce transfert d'activité
donc il ya une urgence à ouvrir et
ouvrir le plus vite possible pour que
tous les achats de noël se passe dans la
plus grande des sérénités pour
l'ensemble des consommateurs
vous avez les beauvaisiennes vous êtes
commerçant sûr
les marchés dans le grand lyon vous
aussi vous sentez clairement monté
la colère oui bien sûr c'est vrai qu'on
a déjà souffert les compliments qualité
capi cent des marchés qui ont dû déposer
le bilan on a beaucoup de collègues et
camarades qui ont dû cesser leurs
activités car elle n'arrivait plus à
payer leurs charges de recharge qui se
sont accrues ces dernières années et ces
dernières années on avait une
conjoncture économique très difficile
c'est très difficile pour nous les
commerçants des marchés depuis des
années est venue se rajouter ce premier
confinement avec cette fille sanitaires
et c'est ce deuxième confinement qui
tombe vraiment à un moment où l'on
réalisé le plus gros de notre chiffre
d'affaires pour savoir que nos ventes de
décembre sont les deux mois on réalise
le plus gros chiffre d'affaires de
l'année on n'est pas des marchés de lyon
des marchés de france et aujourd'hui ce
soir je suis à vous remercier de m'avoir
invité pour relayer la détresse la
détresse de milliers et de milliers de
commerçants de marché qui souffre qui
s'ouvre qu'ils n'avaient plus à faire
vivre leur famille dans la dignité qui
n'arrivent plus à payer leurs charges
il faut savoir que beaucoup d'entre nous
nous ne sommes approvisionnés nous avons
dépensé la majorité de notre capital
pour pouvoir acheter des marchandises et
du jour au lendemain on se retrouve dans
l'impossibilité de ré 10e notre activité
pour nous c'est apple l'injustice parce
qu'on comprend pas pourquoi les groupes
comme amazon se gavent et corée won
on les encourage à réaliser leurs
activités les grandes surfaces car pour
aller jeter un coup d'oeil à car pour
aller jeter un coup d'oeil à auchan et
vous verrez que les conditions
sanitaires n'y sont pas nous avons
respecté dès le premier jour nous avons
joué le jeu des premiers jours nous
avons respecté les dissensions à mettre
50 avec les clients eux mêmes
entre les étals les masques le jeune ali
devant le public nous sommes beaucoup
plus sûr que les grands tubes à son
niveau des conditions sanitaires
donc c'est pour cette raison que ce
traitement la plupart du temps en tout
cas c'est un cri d'un gris dallaire un
cri de détresse je viens reveiller de la
détresse milliers et de milliers de mes
collègues qui sont en souffrance et je
voudrais revenir aussi sur le on parle
de compensation mais comment ils font
les
les collègues depuis le 29 29 octobre la
date la proclamation de l'article 38 du
décret du 29 octobre 2020 comme ils font
ils ont dépensé tout l'argent pour
acheter de la marchandise
aujourd'hui à d'action souffrance il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de mes collègues tous
les jours on s'appelle on se réunit on a
déjà organisé la première manifestation
devant la préfecture le préfet n'a même
pas voulu n'a même pas souhaité nous ne
nous recevoir
comment on trouve seif c'est quand même
un peu scandaleux il aurait pu nous
recevoir
donc on rit on relance un appel à tous
les commerçants non sédentaires et à
tous les commerces
il ya tous ceux qui s'ouvrent à nous
rejoindre le mardi 17 novembre à 15
heures devant la préfecture du rhône
on continue on a envoyé les déclarations
des autorisations de la préfecture et
ont lancé un appel aux crêpes est juste
une question raymond soubie l'ancien
conseiller social de nicolas sarkozy a
visé ce matin les commerçants
potentiellement sont les nouveaux gilet
jaune puissance en est ce que c'est une
analyse rapidement ce qu'on va aussi
donner la parole à notre restaurateur à
ce que c'est une année ce qui me semble
pertinente les nouveaux gilet jaune
puissance ans oui nous sommes persécutés
nous sommes persécutés socialement
économiquement la différence avec les
jets les gens que je respecte beaucoup
nous nous sommes nous sommes atteints
dans notre activité dans notre vie avec
une autre famille on est atteint et on
risque de problèmes qui se passe c'est
que les petites entreprises sont le
premier sur les premiers employeurs de
france des marchés sont les premiers
créateurs de lien intergénérationnel
c'est là on retrouve la parole
excusez moi parce que c'est vrai qu'à 3
il faut le temps de parole pour tout le
monde
les commerçants donc fermé les
restaurateurs également je vais vous
donner la parole dans quelques instants
olivier marais tôt je voudrais d'abord
qu'on regarde un coup de gueule celui de
laurence a fait le buzz
c'est un restaurateur breton à pontivy
lui aussi est fermée vous allez le voir
il est très en colère contre le drive
d'une enseigne de fast food qui lui fait
justement concurrence ouais c'est une
colère ce soir là franchement je suis en
colère quand je veux voir ça joue montre
un petit peu
voilà donc mc do à pontivy voilà là que
là que partout partout partout et satan
satan sunrise
on va attendre pendant quoi une petite
demi-heure machin et thoune juste un
petit coup de fil à passer au restaurant
et moi je vous sers indirectement en 5
minutes vous venez vous cherchez
terminée j'y vois là moi ça me ressemble
ça me débecte je pense que je vais
arrêter l'emporter parce que franchement
voilà je vais je vais éviter de dépenser
de l'argent et olivier marais tôt c'est
vrai que ça fait le buzz aujourd'hui
cette vidéo on comprend la colère de
laurent facettes cette chaîne de
restauration rapide
vous trouvez ça comment déloyale ou
aussi super déloyale en fait là faut pas
nous monter les uns contre les autres
c'est leur métier de faire du drive donc
ils en ont toujours fait et nous le
gouvernement nous a dit faites du click
and collect fait de l'emporter mais
c'est un métier
ainsi vous n'avez pas déjà un fonds de
clientèle et vous avez déjà vous êtes ne
peut-être pas présent déjà auprès de
près de deux personnes
vous n'allez pas vous inventer un
chiffre d'affaires là dessus donc
fatalement vous allez perdre de l'argent
donc sympa de sympa de simple absence
dentaire moi j'ai clairement pas ouvert
on voit entend remporter ça ne sert à
rien sinon on perd encore plus d'argent
oui parce qu'on va perdre encore plus
d'argent qu'on en perd aujourd'hui je
peux vous dire qu'aujourd'hui on perd de
l'argent
une restaurant c'est comme une
entreprise normale
il ya deux choses d'un côté on a on a
des revenus de notre côté on a des
charges le gouvernement claque nous a
retiré 100 % de leurs revenus
1 mais pas 100 % de nos charges donc
aujourd'hui nous on fabrique pas
d'argent et aujourd'hui on a des
échéances qui tombe on a les loyers on a
les frais d'entretien au faux-pas faut
penser que tous nos fournisseurs
généralement les paye à 30 ou 60 jours 1
ce qui veut dire que aujourd'hui on a
nos échéances de nos fournisseurs qui
tombe alors qu'on a plus de rentrées
d'argent
nos trésoreries sont exsangues d'une
façon générale
en temps normal quand une entreprise une
trésorerie exsangue n'a pas de
visibilité
généralement on dit qu'elle court droit
au dépôt
et aujourd'hui ben il ya beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup d'entreprises
qui sont dans ce cas là on a put on n'a
plus de fonds le gouvernement même
aucune haine de la part de l'état vous
avez quand même quelques z encore
aujourd'hui alors concrètement
regardez on nous a coupé nos revenus en
début de mois à 100% d'accord
aujourd'hui le plan leurs salariés une
rapidité est clair pour nous fermer cet
effet en deux jours tak tak là le truc
jeudi soir ont fermé au caire ont fait
un mort en plus on recule 1 euro
aujourd'hui le plan le fonds de
solidarité ne sera accessible pour ceux
qui ont eu le couvre-feu qu'à partir du
20 novembre
mais moi entre le zéro et le 20 novembre
on a déjà là on a on a des factures qui
tomba faut savoir aussi que on a une
prise en charge de nos salaires avec le
chômage partiel le gouvernement alors
moi par exemple je l'avais fait jusqu'au
jusqu'à fin octobre les traits un
renouvellement
aujourd'hui avant c'était trois jours
maintenant c'est quinze jours ouvrables
pour que le dossier soit de nouveau
validé donc là j'en suis à deux mois
d'avancé de salaires donc septembre
octobre où je n'ai toujours pas été
remboursés donc un moment eu encore une
fois je ne fabrique pas d'argent j'ai
pas une planche à billets derrière pour
pour fabricants fabrique les d'argent
comme souvent un problème de trésorerie
en tout cas de plus en plus de
personnalités politiques prennent la
parole pour dénoncer des règles
sanitaires absurde c'est que le car ce
matin d'arnaud montebourg écouter
l'ancien ministre de l'économie il était
chez nos confrères de bfm
je crois que les commerces ne sont pas
les responsables de la propagation du
virus
les décisions qui sont prises sont des
décisions brutales et arbitraire elles
ne sont pas non plus très intelligente
franck mettez vous êtes d'accord avec ce
diagnostic d'arnaud montebourg
il est évident que dans les commerces la
sécurité et les optimale finalement
quand on se torture
un achat quels qu'ils soient eh bien on
est conditionné par le respect des
règles sanitaires pour éviter soit de
propager le virus soit d'attraper le
virus
donc il ya vraiment aujourd'hui une
sécurité totale et encore plus dans les
commerces de proximité ou là vous avez
du personnel qui accueille les clients
les accompagnent et qui fait en sorte
que tout soit bien respecté le port du
masque le gel hydroalcoolique sur les
mains donc il ya des conditions de
sécurité sanitaire qui sont optimales
s'agissant des magasins de jouets on a
proposé d'aller encore plus loin pour
faire en sorte de réguler encore plus
fortement la fréquentation dans les
magasins
tout ça pour garantir la sécurité bien
sûr de nos équipes aussi de nos clients
donc il ya vraiment aujourd'hui aucune
raison on va dire d'ordre sanitaire de
refuser l'accès à un magasin d'autant
plus que par ailleurs on va demander aux
clients de venir dans ses magasins pour
faire du click and collect donc on voit
bien que les conditions sont réunies
c'est simplement lusage qui va changer
un petit peu et pour autant on peut
aujourd'hui garantir à 100%
puisqu'aucun cluster n'a été détectée
dans un magasin quel qu'il soit depuis
le 11 mai date de fin du premier
confinement donc c'est très sûrs d'eux
venu faire ses achats dans un magasin
aujourd'hui on a vu une autre milice de
l'économie bruno le maire encourager
fortement à voile a évolué vers le
digital abdelaziz boudé mediène ça vous
inspire quoi cet encouragement de bruno
le maire oui merci bruno le maire de
donner des conseils mais mettre en place
le click and collect ça se fait pas du
jour au lendemain comme le disait alors
mon collègue
c'est une façon de faire c'est une façon
de travailler c'est une façon d'agir
c'est une certaine forme formation qu'on
va qu'on doit acquérir également pour
pouvoir réaliser du travail sur le net
le e-commerce c'est pas donné à tout le
monde on n'a jamais été formés nous on
nature était sur le terrain nous notre
façon de vendre c'est sur les marchés on
a toujours été sur les marchés
et comme vous le disait depuis thaler
donc on a remboursé on a joué le jeu
donc on a établi toutes les règles de
distanciation des réalités génois
coliques les masques masque obligatoire
pour les clients et pour les commerçants
et on est
à durcir les règles sanitaires des prêts
à revoir cahier des charges n'est prêt à
jouer le jeu on peut pas du jour au
lendemain ce sens est de 15 en un clic
en collet savaient très bien que les
clients du marché les commerçants et des
clients
nos clients font partie du 4 populaire
c'est des gens des personnes âgées des
personnes avec des faibles revenus dont
qui n'ont pas ce qu'ils n'ont pas
l'instinct d'acheter sur le sur le net
la gestion le net et qui préfèrent venir
' sur le marché et je tiens j'ai eu
beaucoup de témoignages de personnes qui
viennent sur le marché du client et
beaucoup qui sont dans la détresse
beaucoup d'angoissé beaucoup de
dépression savaient ils ont besoin de
sortir ils ont besoin de rencontrer
d'autres personnes ils ont besoin de
venir à notre rencontre et je pense que
c'est un peu on n'est pas contre on sait
très bien quelle pandémie
on est conscient qu'un danger mais on a
tout mis en place pour qu'il n'y ait
absolument aucun risque on n'a eu aucun
souci
moi j'invite le préfère le ministre de
l'économie bruno le maire à nous à nous
sortir un cluster qu'on arrive sur un
marché à l'hôtel de marché on n'a eu
aucun souci sur les marchés les marchés
sont en plein air
les règles sont respectées est ce que je
voudrais dire c'est qu'il ya une
injustice pour nom trouve que c'est
injuste que les grandes surfaces où les
gens s'entassent les uns contre les
autres soient ouverts et qu'on leur
permette de réseaux l'activité et que
nous ne seront sanctionnés c'est
absolument pas normal
et aussi également la fnac et darty je
trouve inacceptable que ces deux
enseignes prennent l'initiative d'ouvrir
et qu'il n'y ait aucune réponse de
l'état s'abstienne demain nous si on
décide de déballer je peux vous assurer
qu'ils vont nous envoyer les crs et que
l'on ait fait remballer donc il faut
absolument la démocratie il faut qu'elle
soit appliquée à la démarrer tôt sur les
propos d'un abs this good men viennent
c'est vrai que par exemple on a vu
hier on a passé et si même un sujet qui
montrait qu'en espagne c'est l inverse
on avait plutôt favoriser les petits
commerçants en tout cas voilà on les a
pas contre un il y en a plutôt fermé les
grands on est clairement en train
d'opposer la santé physique et la santé
économique et les petits en pâtissent le
plus oui puis si vous allez en suède
aujourd'hui tout est ouvert et ils ont
jamais rien fermé donc manifestement il
ya différentes voies qui était possible
notre gouvernement a choisi une mais en
s'obstinant dans cette voie ils nous
marquent aussi d'une façon très forte
j'estime - ou trop forte
quand je vois les images des cantines
scolaires et dépendent de l'état où les
élèves sont entassés les uns contre les
autres
1 quand on pense que dans les
restaurants d'entreprise c'est
exactement le cas alors que nous on a
installé les gens avec la distanciation
avec un protocole qui avait été négociée
par les tanks et est facilement
vérifiable et d'ailleurs qui était
vérifiée puisque on avait plusieurs fois
la visite inde et des policiers on se
dit il ya deux poids deux mesures
clairement et on a vraiment l'impression
d'être stigmatisés parce qu'on est petit
1 parce que parce qu'on est petit on est
sur la survie notre entreprise on n'a
pas le temps de se soutenir les uns les
autres d'une façon trop forte et donc
c'est un petit peu facile de nous mettre
sous l'éteignoir et c'est terrible
aujourd'hui c'est terrible je me tourne
vers vous franco a maté on parlait de
noël évidemment les jouets forcément le
nerf de la guerre pour vous on imagine
que ça peut être potentiellement une
catastrophe
il en va de la survie de nos commerces
en fête puisque pour nos magasins de
jouets novembre décembre ça représente
50 % de notre chiffre d'affaires annuel
donc vous imaginez que pour l'instant on
a payé 10 mois de charge et on espérait
pouvoir atteindre l' équilibre de nos
magasins avec cette période de vente
très forte pour nous ça ne sera pas le
cas en tout cas pour les 15 premiers
jours de laurent qui représente déjà
deux moitiés d'affaires pour nous donc
on est vraiment dans
un mode survie et on espère que le
gouvernement va entendre nos arguments
20 considéré qu effectivement compte
tenu de la très forte saisonnalité de
notre activité
il ne faut pas attendre le dernier
moment pour ouvrir parce que la sert à
créer des mouvements de foule très
important de la panique les clients
aujourd'hui sont très angoissés à l'idée
de pouvoir acheter leurs jouets ils
veulent revenir dans les magasins parce
qu'ils veulent voir les jouets ils
veulent se rend compte de ce que le père
noël va déposer au pied du sapin
donc pour nous c'est extrêmement
important que l'ouverture des magasins
soit annoncée dès demain pour que dès
vendredi 13 novembre nous puissions
accueillir nos clients dans le plus
grand des gauchos effectivement demain
conseil de défense marine le pen elle a
lancé un avertissement au gouvernement
sur la situation des commerçants juste
avant peut-être de nouvelles annonces de
jean castex demain écouter la présidente
du rassemblement national gilles décidé
de maintenir ces commerces fermés
évidemment que chaque jour qui passe le
risque est plus grand de voir ses
artisans ses indépendant et ses
commerçants mettre la clé sous la porte
avec le cortège évidemment de chômeurs
qui en sera la conséquence et delhaize
et comédienne vous allez pas contredire
j'imagine marine le pen vous parler tous
les jours avec vous vos collègues
quels sont les risques que vous craignez
vous savez tous les jours je suis en
contact avec mes collègues et j'arrive à
ressentir cette ce désespoir il ya un
certain désespoir nebbou beaucoup de nos
collègues des commerçants des marchés
qui me disent que vous n'y arrive plus
que comme qu'est ce qu'on va devenir
au niveau des aides de l'état donc
n'arriveront pas avant fin novembre
début décembre et même au niveau du
calcul calcul qui est absolument pas
cauvin qui est pas juste au niveau du
calcul de compensation le premier qu'on
filme en a beaucoup de commerçants dont
qui ont déclaré trop tard et qu'il
n'était absolument pas indemnisé n'ont
pas touché de prime de l'étape de
compensation de l'état
on a des gens jour d'aujourd'hui qui ont
des factures pions des dettes
il y en a qui ont des crédits et il y en
a qui l'ont qui s'angoissent énormément
donc au c'est vraiment un
un cri de désespoir que je viens
c'est ce soir en direction du préfère en
direction du gouvernement en direction
du président emmanuel macron on est tous
ensemble on est sur le même navire on
sait très bien qu'à l'ère condé me mais
il ya d'autres solutions il ya d'autres
solutions il ya d'autres alternatives
on parle des hôpitaux qui sont saturés
je rappelle que des cliniques privées
des hôpitaux privés ne sont pas mises à
contribution
je rappelle également qu'il ya beaucoup
de peau s'il ya beaucoup de solutions
notamment sur les marchés
les conditions sanitaires tir de là on
peut les renforcer il n'y a absolument
aucun risque
donc je pense qu'il faut qu'on puisse
travailler dans la cohérence et dans la
justice pour que tout le monde puisse
espérer parce qu'au jour d'aujourd'hui
les gens désespèrent
donc il ya bruno le maire qui nous a dit
attendez le 12
on va réévaluer la situation peut-être
que grâce de mailhac à ce texte qui va
nous annoncer que l'écouté n'y comptez
pas il comptait pas il ya trop demandant
les ehpad trop de morts dans les
hôpitaux les salles d'animation sont
saturés donc là on angoisse on angoisse
terriblement donc là on espère que il y
aura quand même un espoir on remercie
aussi des mères et des dizaines de
maires dont qui ont signé des arrêtés
pour pouvoir brute des marchés il ya des
députés également qui nous soutiennent
donc on les remercie tous du fond du
coeur et on espère que qu'une solution
ne sera proposée sur ton stopper ratuvou
disait novembre décembre si on rate
cette période on est cuit on est cuit
parce que ces visites est en tout cas
merci à tous les trois frank mather ne
jouer que la veillée nous excuser pour
la petite erreur de voile annonce n y
désaisissement mediène également et
olivier marzotto merci beaucoup à tous
les trois d'avoir apportez vos
témoignages en direct sur rt france
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons de la présidentielle
américaine
la géorgie qui va procéder à un
recomptage des voix donald trump et joe
biden sont dans un mouchoir de poche
dans cet état et puis nous parlerons des
relations entre les etats-unis et israël
le premier ministre israélien
trouvera-t-il en joe biden un aussi
fervent défenseur de cette politique
on y répondra avec notre correspondant
sur place à tel-aviv
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins et
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
comment on peut expliquer que d'un
groupe est énorme comme areva qui est
spécialisé puisse acheter des mines
inexploitables ce n'est pas explicable
mais ça permet d'envoyer aussi des
gratifications on va dire à des à des
politiciens nigérien la gestion de
fantaisiste d'areva a des répercussions
incroyable jusqu'au président américain
obama donne son accord pour qu'areva
bénéficie d'un prêt de 2 milliards de
dollars alors que l'agent ce qui est
censé gérer ces prêts un avis négatif
je ne suis pas pour ou contre le
nucléaire je suis simplement pour une
industrie sans corruption parce que
cette industrie là si elle crée un
incident c'est pour l'éternité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
petits échos positifs n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité d idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent
elle conçoit vient de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui une gauche l'extrême
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt france
si vous nous rejoignez il est 20h30
heure française
aux etats unis plus d'une semaine après
l'élection le bras de fer continue entre
démocrates et républicains
donald trump refuse toujours de concéder
sa défaite et lance des procédures
judiciaires tandis que joe biden reçoit
déjà les félicitations de dirigeants
internationaux
nous sommes en direct avec un autre
reporter un bonnet en direct de
washington bonsoir thomas où en est on
dans cette opposition entre républicains
et démocrates
eh bien les équipes de donald trump
continue de lancer des procédures
judiciaires dans un certain nombre
d'états et on a eu la confirmation
aujourd'hui qu'il y aurait un recomptage
total des bulletins dans l'état de
géorgie il faut dire que dans cet état
l'écart est particulièrement serré entre
les deux candidats on parle d'un peu
plus de 15 mille voix d'écart l'annoncé
a été faite aujourd'hui par le
secrétaire de l'état de géorgie qui a
tenu une conférence de presse je vous
propose d'écouter un extrait à ce jour
97 comté ont fait remonter le décompte
final
l'écart actuel et de 14000 111 voix
entre le président et le sénateur byden
le vice président biden
mon bureau va continuer d'enquêter sur
chacun des cas de votes illégaux de
double vote de vote criminels condamnés
de personnes ayant voté dans un état qui
n'est pas le leur si vous signaler
quelque chose nous enquêterons tous les
votes légaux seront pris en compte
nous allons continuer à respecter et
faire appliquer la loi
la prochaine étape du processus
électoral c'est la confirmation des
résultats par les comptes et puis le
risque limiting audit le contrôle de
limitation des risques débutera à 13h je
désignerai officiellement l'élection qui
sera soumise à ce contrôle avec des
écarts si réduit cela nécessitera un
recomptage à la main dans chaque comté
cela apaisera les doutes ce sera à la
fois un contrôle un recomptage et une
confirmation
ce sera du gros travail mais mille
coopérons avec les comptes et pour en
avoir fini avant la date de confirmation
des résultats au niveau de l'état et
puis de son côté le camp démocrate s'est
dit regretter le fait que la transition
au sommet du pouvoir fédéral soit bloqué
il faut dire que l'administration de la
maison blanche ne reconnais pas la
victoire de joe biden l'ancien vice
président qui a pris la parole ce mardi
depuis la ville de wilmington dans son
fief du
de l'ovaire il a été interrogé sur la
stratégie adoptée ces derniers jours par
donald trump
je vous propose d'écouter je pense que
c'est une source d'embarras
honnêtement la seule chose qui comment
dire cela avec tact je crois que cela ne
servira pas à l'héritage du président
règle et comment thomas réagissent les
partisans des deux candidats ce bras de
fer qui dure
bien vous avez d'un côté les pro ben
hayden qui balaye les accusations du
camp républicain estimant qu'il s'agit
de fausses informations qui émanent de
personnes qui ont du mal à accepter leur
défaite et puis du côté des pros trump
on est à la recherche de tout élément
qui pourrait attester cette thèse de la
fraude généralisée il ya beaucoup de
choses qui circulent sur les réseaux
sociaux les réseaux sociaux il est
parfois c'est difficile de démêler le
vrai du faux je vous donne un exemple le
témoignage de richard hopkins et un
employé du service postal de
pennsylvanie qui affirme qu'il a entendu
des consignes de la part de son
employeur adressé à l'un de ses
collègues et qui visait a antidaté les
bulletins arrivé après le 3 novembre 7
ce témoignage a beaucoup circulé sur les
réseaux sociaux et puis le washington
post a affirmé que le principal
intéressé s'était finalement rétracté
lors de son audition devant les
enquêteurs c'est que lui même a gagné
dans une vidéo diffusée sur youtube il a
aligné donc la version du washington
post demandant même au journal de
retirer son article et puis dans un
tweet donald trump a qualifié le jeune
employé du service postal de
pennsylvanie de patriotes
courageux les partisans donald trump qui
ont également lancé un mouvement stop
the style arrêter le vol un slogan en
signe de ralliement pour tous ceux qui
sont aux côtés du président donald trump
dans son combat judiciaire un groupe
facebook avaient été créées est en train
de devenir virale et plus il a été
finalement supprimé par les modérateurs
du réseau social qu'ils ont considéré
qu'il s'agissait d'une incitation à la
violence malgré tout ça des soutiens du
président ont décidé d'organiser un
grand rassemblement ce samedi à
proximité de la maison blanche donc ici
à washington plusieurs centaines de
personnes voire plusieurs milliers de
personnes on verra combien répondront à
cet appel lancé sur les réseaux sociaux
le but vous l'avez compris c'est
d'afficher leur soutien au président
donald trump dans son combat contre ce
que certains qualifient ici de fraude
ont ce scrutin électoral
merci thomas bonnin en direct de
washington
et pour continuer à parler de cette
élection américaine nous sommes avec
yannick mireur politologue spécialiste
des états unis bonsoir yannick mireur
merci d'être avec nous à ce que vous
êtes surpris par la tournure de cette
élection au de l'élection elle même
évidemment parce que c'était assez serré
c'est un regain de participation
extraordinaire des voix gagnées par
millions par les deux candidats
même séparés par un vote populaire au
qui tourne autour de 5 millions de voix
mais comment dirais-je un rattrapage
candidat démocrate précisément ce qui au
moins là il n'y en a pas eu d'erreur sur
les prédictions grâce au vote par
correspondance
il y aura en effet et tous expliquent
largement bénéficié et puis une sorte de
résistance un petit peu futiles pour
tout dire du président sortant puisque
je ne pense pas que ce soit un battre r
je pense que l' affaire est entendue et
que de la même manière qu'avec une
certaine désinvolture
monsieur trump et aller jouer au golf et
bien de son côté messieurs maiden se met
au travail
il n'est pas question de démocrates et
de républicains de 3 en cours de bail
donne simplement il ya une élection il
ya un gagnant il ya un pays qui traverse
une crise sanitaire qui n'a pas été
prise au sérieux par la précédente
administration
donc il est urgent de mettre en oeuvre
un plan sanitaire fédérale qui coordonne
l'action et et à diffuser l'information
des lic fiable aux citoyens américains
etc
c'est ça l'urgence donc une est un petit
peu navrant embarrassant c'est vrai je
reprends le mot du président élu que la
situation soit celle qu'elle est devant
nous mais je ne pense pas qu'il ira
chaos non plus je pense que
il ya des échéances une décembre le 14
décembre pour la réunion du collège
électoral cetera d'ici là les les
résultats sont tout à fait connu entre
temps pas plus que des derniers jours
les recours déposés par les organismes
républicain dans les états où la
campagne du candidat trump n'a eu gain
de cause puisqu'il s'agit de contester
l'enregistrement de certains bulletins
de vote après une certaine heure par
rapport à la règle de l'état de
contester lusage de stabilo boss
il ya eu toute une petite une
conspiration sur les réseaux sociaux là
dessus sur l'usagé stabilo boss plutôt
que des stylos à pointe
bref et le monsieur raphaël guère que
vous venez de faire voir secrétaire
d'état c'est à dire le ministre de
l'intérieur lisons de géorgie est un
républicain et donc s'il y avait une
véritable faute fraude là où on peine
sylvanie de manière aussi massive que ce
serait nécessaire pour qu'il y ait
changement de résultat ça se verrait
assez facilement donc tout ceci n'est
pas très surprenant et je pense que si
on en croit les rumeurs la famille
l'entourage de monsieur trompe
lui-même se divisent avec celui le seul
qui a eu des fonctions officielles
maison blanche son gendre qui semble
qu'il tendrait à essayer de le
convaincre de jeter l'épongé il y aurait
intérêt puisque
changera monsieur ben laden est le 46e
président des états unis et il aurait
plutôt intérêt lui-même à sortir sinon
élégamment ce m'étonnerait beaucoup mais
en tous les cas devenir raisonnable de
cette situation alors beaucoup en tout
cas yannick mireur parle du déni du
président trump est ce que c'est
vraiment la bonne analyse qu'il faut
avoir c'est du déni ou tout simplement
c'est une stratégie de la part du
président républicain
bon je pense qu'il n'est pas fou je ne
suis pas d'une question de déni il était
possible dans les premières heures ça
peut se ça peut se concevoir
mais au point où on en est et où toutes
les chancelleries du monde entier les
unes après les autres
félicite le candidat au moment où aussi
un ancien président des états unis
monsieur bush républicain féliciter
monsieur bart hayden est aussi avancée
il a fait plus que si je puis me
permettre le service minimum le
président bush il a aussi déclaré très
clairement que le processus électoral
aux états unis avait été parfaitement
transparent qu'il n'y avait pas lieu de
s'inquiéter de fraudes massives sinon de
petites irrégularités ici là ça arrive
même en france ou ailleurs je crois que
ni plus qu'à sion de dénis aujourd'hui
c'est plus une question de tactique ou
de stratégie j'ai du mal à y voir clair
d'ailleurs là dedans mais monsieur trêve
nous a habitués à des choses très
erratique et contradictoires toutes les
chancelleries pardonnez moi vous dites
toutes les chancelleries les unes après
les autres le félicitent en fait quand
même pas le cas de tout le monde
tout le monde ne l'a pas félicité israël
a salué joe biden mais n'a pas félicité
la russie la chine certains attendent
des résultats officiels puisque à partir
du moment où on demande un recomptage
qu'il est en droit de faire même s'il a
peut-être peu de chances de l'emporter
et bien c'est compliqué de le féliciter
n'est ce pas non vous n'adhérez pas en
tout cas c'est ce postulat non je joue
je crois je ne crois pas je pense que
les pays notamment les alliés
traditionnels des états unis france
allemagne canada angleterre
pourtant dieu sait si on a bien close et
sur l'amitié particulière entre monsieur
johnson et monsieur train pour leur
façon de voir les choses d'une manière
semblable bref monsieur johnson n'a pas
perdu de temps pour reconnaître la
situation
je ne crois pas les vins la turquie
aussi l'a fait donc tout confondu
démocratie représentative origines plus
autoritaire donc la chose et la chose et
est avancé et pour ce qui est des
recours ou absolument ils sont tout à
fait légaux comme je vous le dit tout à
l'heure il ya des dates et je pense que
monsieur trump devrait jouer sur ces
dates mais aulas du d'un mois ou un mois
et demi il n'y a plus guère de
possibilité puisque les résultats sont
rendus s'agissant par exemple de la
géorgie la géorgie avait déjà que ça
fait partie de ce code électoral notre
correspondant l'a rappelé la marge de
2,2 de différences entre les deux
candidats est tel 05 % lequel inclut
automatiquement un recomptage des voix
mais on sait aussi qu historiquement le
recomptage des voix ne livre guère de
surprise d'autant que si vous regardez
les chiffres n'ont pas la proportion de
différences entre les deux mais le
nombre de bulletins que cela concerne
plus de dix mille bulletins
c'est difficile de concevoir une erreur
sur 10000 butin est donc l'histoire
montre que lorsqu'il ya un recomptage
mais bien souvent c'est le même résultat
qui en ressort beaucoup d'américains
nous disait sur place que finalement le
pire aujourd'hui aux etats-unis c'était
cette division et qu'ils espéraient
dans cette élection que ces divisions
sais c'est ce que justement les derniers
développements vont
en ce sens c'est ce qu'on peut décemment
être optimiste écoutez par nature je le
suis
il faut espérer qu'avec sa longue
expérience et malgré la faiblesse de sa
candidature mais la période
extraordinaire qu'il traverse dans sa
vie monsieur byden saura trouver les
mots je dirais que son discours
jusque-là d'apaisement et de
conciliation nationale était celui qu'il
fallait il est regrettable que trump eux
n'est pas une attitude comparables
ensuite il faut se projeter plus loin il
y aura une administration démocrate
maiden pendant les quatre ans qui
viennent
la question est de savoir quel sera
l'héritage de monsieur trump qui a su
parler à des classes populaires et
moyennes
méprisé négligées ou oubliées temps par
la droite du parti républicain que par
la gauche du parti démocrate
c'est cet héritage là qui me semble
salutaire même s'il l'a fait de manière
très abrasives emportant la division au
sein du pays mais c'est une intuition
juste qu'il a eue de la même manière
pendant internationale sur la chine par
exemple maintenant il ya consensus dans
la classe politique et les affaires aux
états unis pour être assez ferme
vis-à-vis de la chine
donc la question de savoir comment son
héritage surtout en politique intérieure
si c'est votre question va se décliner
quelle sera l'attitude l'orientation du
parti républicain et de la même manière
du côté démocrate puisque ce sont deux
parties qui sont un peu comme si non des
câlins sans tête en tous les cas sont
depuis bien longtemps maintenant divisée
manque de leadership de cohésion et de
et de vue de projets et nationale a
proposé aux américains et donc c'est
seulement ce travail là de part et
d'autre qui permettra je pense d'eux des
d'atténuer cette polarisation dans le
climat que nous connaissons je pense que
les états unis pourront pourrons
surmonter cela mais c'est la
responsabilité de monsieur bart hayden
et des leaders républicains en
particulier au sénat merci yannick
mireur politologue spécialiste des états
unis d'avoir été
avec nous et alors que donald trump
multiplie les recours en justice contre
les résultats de l'élection
présidentielle un autre combat politique
c'est ouvert celui de la course au sénat
un enjeu crucial pour le futur président
des états unis est pour l'instant les
républicains semblent tenir la corde les
précisions de cyrielle beau et la
bataille entre démocrates et
républicains se poursuit aux états unis
dans la ligne de mire des deux parties
le sénat organe clé de la politique
américaine
si le parti de joe biden est assuré de
conserver le contrôle de la chambre des
représentants
le sort du sénat à lui reste incertain
et pour cause
sur les 100 sièges disponibles au sein
de cette assemblée 49 sont occupés par
des républicains contre 40 8 côté
démocrate
à l'heure actuelle seuls trois sièges
sont encore à pourvoir 1 en alaska et de
en géorgie si pour le premier et à les
résultats provisoires sont en faveur du
sénateur sortant républicain dans le
second les démocrates sont encore en
position de l'emporter
et maintenant nous prenons la géorgie et
nous changeons le monde
cet état du sud est n'a pourtant pas
voter pour un candidat démocrate à la
présidentielle
depuis 1992 et n'a pas eu de sénateurs
de ce parti depuis 2005
la géorgie est le seul état avec la
louisiane où la majorité absolue est
requise pour entrer au sénat après des
résultats serrés un second tour se
tiendra le 5 janvier prochain pour
départager les deux camps
ces derniers ont donc moins de deux mois
pour mobiliser leurs électeurs
si les démocrates parviennent à obtenir
les deux sièges du pitch tate l'égalité
sera parfaite au sein du sénat
dans ce cas précis et selon la
constitution
la vice-présidente kamala harris en sa
qualité de président du sénat serait
amené à départager les votes
une situation qui tournerait à
l'avantagé du parti démocrate
mais pourquoi une telle bataille pour
obtenir le sénat tout simplement parce
que sans son appui
le président américain aura très peu de
marge de manoeuvre
aucune loi ne peut être adoptée sans la
chambre haute qui possède également le
pouvoir d'approuver ou non certaines
nominations majeur émanant de la maison
blanche
en cas de majorité républicaine au sénat
joe biden devrait alors composer avec un
congrès américain diviser plutôt sombre
cette éventualité est balayée par joe
biden qui pensent pouvoir rassembler
suffisamment de parlementaires pour
voter certains textes importants
notamment celui consacré à la relance de
l'économie
l élection américaine a été suivi de
très près à l'étranger notamment en
israël sous l'administration trump le
premier ministre israélien en trouver un
fervent défenseur de sa politique mais
la tendance a basculé côté démocrate
comme sous barack obama ou les relations
avec benyamin nétanyahou était houleuse
joe biden son vice président d'alors
s'était montré moins violent mais ces
promesses de campagne pourrait trancher
avec la politique de son prédécesseur et
midi goût gâche un allié clef pour
israël c'est ainsi que benyamin
nétanyahou a présenté donald trump le
premier ministre israélien a rappelé les
avancées qu'a permis le président
républicain sortant pour israël et plus
largement au moyen-orient je tiens de
nouveau à remercier mon très grand ami
de malte rome pour le soutien formidable
qu'il a accordé à israël la
reconnaissance de jérusalem comme
capitale d'israël et le transfert de
l'ambassade américaine dans cette ville
la reconnaissance de notre souveraineté
sous le plateau du golan sa position
très ferme contre l'iran son soutien
constant à l'onu le renforcement des
liens de sécurité les accords de paix
donald trump dont les positions ont
marqué une rupture avec celle de ses
prédécesseurs notamment barack obama
les huit années du président démocrate à
la tête des états unis sont marquées par
des relations houleuses avec le premier
ministre israélien
elle s'achève par ce qui sera perçu par
israël comme un coup de poignard dans le
dos le 23 décembre 2016 le conseil de
sécurité vote une résolution de l'onu
condamnant la colonisation israélienne
la création par israël de colonies de
peuplement dans le territoire
palestinien occupé depuis 1967 y compris
jérusalem est n'a aucun fondement en
droit
fait inédit depuis 1979
les etats unis sont le seul pays
à s'abstenir une abstention historique
de la part de ce pays allié elle permet
l'adoption de cette résolution
vice-président de barack obama joe biden
semble lui avoir les faveurs de benyamin
nétanyahou bien qu'il soit également
démocrate
le premier ministre israélien décrit une
amitié de longue date
je tiens à féliciter joe biden et kamala
harris
j'ai une relation personnelle
chaleureuse est longue avec joe biden
depuis près de 40 ans je le connais en
tant que grand ami de l'état d'israël
je suis sûr que nous continuerons de
travailler tous les deux pour continuer
et renforcer l'alliance spéciale entre
israël et les états unis mais comme
écrit dans ses promesses de campagne
celui qui est désigné comme président et
l'ue prévoit de rouvrir le consulat
américain à jérusalem est ainsi que la
mission de l'ol paie l'organisation de
libération de la palestine à washington
donald trump l'avait fermé il y a deux
ans des promesses qui pourrait présager
un nouveau revirement dans les rapports
entre washington et tel aviv ou en tout
cas une relation moins complaisante avec
israël c'est avec nous dans quelques
instants nous parlerons de l'europe
frappé de plein fouet par la deuxième
vague de qu'ovide les premières
vaccinations devraient être envisageable
au premier trimestre 2001 21 précise
l'union européenne et puis direction le
brésil germolles son art au continue de
minimiser la pandémie d'abord suspendu
les essais cliniques
phase iii d'un vaccin chinois reprennent
finalement
[Musique]
quand vous voyez ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui avec cette deuxième vague
avec ce deuxième au film en est ce qu'on
pouvait faire autrement plus vous
dépister - les jambes et ça a été vu en
allemagne quatre fois moins de voix
qu'en france ça a été vue un autriche 4
fois moins de morts provence a été vu en
corée du sud etc
ça ne profite pas de ce deuxième
peaufinement pour que des pistes et
systématique que montrent les choses
vont recommencer
il y aura une troisième vague au
printemps et un troisième confinement et
ce pays sera évidemment cloués au sol
[Musique]
la france oubliée c'est une rencontre
avec ces citoyens qui ne se résignent
pas à la fatalité
on est comme tout le monde même si on
n'est pas en appartement on est énervé
dans l sentiment qu'il faut à chaque
fois se battre ils vivent parfois au
bord des routes nationales pas forcément
loin de paris mais toujours moins de
ceux qui les dirigent
moi je remarque qu'on y passe un sur
deux tracteurs et cnooc meilleure
campagne il faut savoir c'est une vie
différente
ils ont le sentiment d'être des français
de seconde zone comme s'ils étaient
invisibles ma forêt et dévoile un peu
plus aujourd'hui la france oubliée c'est
montrer ce qu'on ne voit jamais
[Musique]
à l'époque il y avait une concurrence
qui était assez violente d'ailleurs
entre les russes et les américains alors
que j'étais destinée à voler avec les
russes mais une opportunité s'est
ouverte de faire partie du deuxième
groupe d'astronautes européens qui m'a
envoyé aussitôt à la nasa
et là j'ai une chance extraordinaire de
la nasa m'a entraîné qualifié affecté en
vol comme un des leurs on est loin de la
guerre des étoiles à en est quand même
dans une espèce de con fraternité et de
solidarité l'exploration au sens large
est une activité en coopération
internationale où on se rend service
entre nations qui pourtant au même
moment son sujet d'embargo et de
conflits géopolitiques savoir est ce que
l'homme peut vivre et travailler dans
l'espace est ce qu'il existe de la vie
ailleurs
est ce qu'on pourra un jour s'installer
durablement sur d'autres corps célestes
tout ça on le fait en coopération
internationale malgré des tensions
à la surface de nos terres
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'on nous trouve le
peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez comme moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du public
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers uniforme c'est quand même
des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas la double hic
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est on dirait qu il y a quand
même la liberté je vous remercie de
m'avoir invité
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
pieds coût politique a jamais été obligé
de dire la vérité mais idée courageuse
des mots qui comptent la haine en soi
vient des lignes ans
aujourd'hui on a une gauche extrême
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
l'euro numérique nous dit la bce
existerait donc parallèlement aux
espèces sans les remplacer
évidemment ils avancent masqués ils vont
pas vous dire dès le départ on fait ça
pour supprimer le yach l'abonné c'est
déjà numérique ou tant que c'est
numérique
c'est clair que le papier-monnaie france
est condamnée à terme
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que fait la banque
centrale elle récupère le système
technologique et elle se l'approprient
si vous avez une patrimoine aujourd'hui
vous regardez avec l'anxiété votre
portefeuille ou des matins c'est pas du
tout cas pour votre compte en banque ont
moqué sauveuse banques traditionnelles
ça s'inscrit dans un mouvement qui est
là depuis déjà plusieurs années qui est
d'avoir le plus de renseignements de ce
que vous faites pour vous utilisez comme
un produit
peut-être que c'est le le modèle dont
rêve
nos dirigeants actuels
[Musique]
chaque jour en politique des milliers de
parties d'échecs se jouer mais les
règles ne sont pas toujours respectées
les couleurs changent de camp les pions
prennent la place des rois deux films
stratégies peuvent porter des résultats
inattendus
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire
[Musique]
monsieur les chômeurs et chaque semaine
dans l'échiquier mondial nous
analyserons les coups les plus complexes
du jeu politique internationale
[Musique]
à bientôt sur rt france il n'y a pas une
façon plus pauvres de défendre un
système que de dire qu'il est moins pire
qu'un autre le peuple c'était une
volonté collective
vous le savez pour moi qui ai des condi
ya pas alternatif on sort du technique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu livre l'uniforme c'est quand même
des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas la public
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté vous
remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
il est 21h heure de paris merci de nous
rejoindre pour celles deuxième heure
d'information tout de suite voici les
titres de l'actualité de ce mercredi 11
novembre une agence spécifique pour
affronter les futures crises sanitaires
c'est la proposition de l'union
européenne allant ce encourageantes les
premières vaccinations sur le vieux
continent devraient être envisageable au
premier trimestre 2001 21
la deuxième vague 2 co vide elle sévit
toujours l'italie est à son tour
submergé une situation des clips comme
hors de contrôle par les médecins outre
atlantique gien bol sudaro continue de
minimiser la pandémie le président
brésilien appelle la population à lutter
dignement contre le coc vide à délaisser
les principes de précaution
d'abord suspendu les essais cliniques de
phase iii d'un vaccin chinois reprennent
finalement s'ils ont des noms plus de
cent soixante deux mille morts du vide
au brésil la popularité du président est
loin d'en pâtir
[Musique]
le contournement de l'accord avec
l'union européenne boris johnson essuie
un refus de la part des lords qui ont
retoqué certaines dispositions et
s'aligne ainsi sur bruxelles un revers
cinglant pour le premier ministre
britannique alors que les discussions
commerciales pauvre excite ont repris
depuis lundi et ne reste plus que
quelques jours à londres et l union
européenne pour s'accorder le retour des
réfugiés conférence ce mercredi à damas
une nécessité pour reconstruire
l'aciérie selon bachar el-assad beaucoup
d'enjeu pour cette réunion soutenue par
la russie l'onu et présente en tant
qu'observateur pour la première fois
depuis le début de la guerre en mars
2011 et le liban et sera représentée par
son ministre des affaires sociales
la crise sanitaire avec cette annonce
concernant les premières vaccinations
contre le comique 19 dans l'union
européenne alors que la situation de
l'épidémie en europe serait très très
inquiétante avec des indicateurs dans le
mauvais sens les premières vaccinations
pourrait-elle avoir lieu au premier
trimestre 2001 21 dans un scénario
optimiste c'est en tout cas ce
qu'indique la directrice du centre
européen de prévention et de contrôle
des maladies
bien sûr le vaccin est prometteur et il
s'agit d'un communiqué de presse et pas
encore d'un examen par les pairs
nous devons donc voir quelle sera
l'évaluation finale la production de
vaccin doit commencer après l'octroi des
licences et l'octroi des licences ne
peut commencer qu'après les essais donc
pour le moment les essais sont toujours
en cours certains sont plus avancés que
d'autres
puis ces informations pour les essais
doivent être envoyées à lagence des
médicaments qui doit les examiner et
accorder ou non une licence de son côté
la russie assure que son vaccin spoutnik
5 et efficace dans 92% des cas c'est ce
qu'a annoncé dans un communiqué que le
fonds le fonds souverains russes et
l'institut de recherche gamaleya pour le
ministre hongrois des affaires
étrangères des négociations sont en
cours concernant les premières
livraisons du vaccin hongrie nous avons
convenu que la hongrie était disposé à
acheter le vaccin russe nous considérons
réaliste d'effectuer des premières
petite livraison en décembre afin de
mener des essais cliniques et des
examens nécessaires en hongrie dans la
deuxième quinzaine de janvier
il sera peut-être possible d'acheter
davantage de doses du vaccin russe nous
avons appris aujourd'hui que le premier
rapport d' analyse provisoire du vaccin
spoutnik v avait été présenté
selon ce rapport son efficacité est de
92%
ce qui constitue une bonne nouvelle
l'italie a dépassé le million de cas du
nouveau coronavirus la situation
épidémique est préoccupante certains
médecins demandent la mise en place d'un
confinement total alors que le pays
enregistre entre 30 et 40 mille nouveaux
cas de contamination chaîne jour les
hôpitaux sont sous forte tension
françois xavier lambert devant les
urgences de l'hôpital napolitain de
communio la file d'attenté ne diminue
pas bouteilles d'oxygène à la main les
infirmières circule au milieu des
voitures pour venir en aide aux
personnes en difficultés respiratoires
qui attendent d'être pris en charge ces
scènes sont devenues habituelles dans la
région de naples l'une des zones qui
recense le plus de cas de kovy de 19
face à cet afflux de patients les
médecins sont débordés
aujourd'hui mon père ne m'a pas répondu
au téléphone et je suis inquiet nous
avons appelé un médecin il nous a dit
que tous les médecins du quartier sont
en isolement parce qu'ils ont tous le
coc vide
c'était le médecin de garde il ne savait
rien pour tenter de maîtriser la
deuxième vague de l'épidémie le
gouvernement a décidé de classer les 20
régions italiennes en trois catégories
quatre régions ont ainsi été placé en
zone rouge ou en confinement strict est
censé être en vigueur
mais face à l'aggravation de la
situation de plus en plus d'hôpitaux
doigt des programmes et les opérations
et examens prévus pour d'autres
pathologies
les autres maladies ne font pas la grève
parce qu'il ya le coc vide et il faut
s'organiser car autrement la pandémie
finira par faire des dégâts qui vont au
delà du déjà très triste grand nombre de
morts pour éviter de se retrouver dans
la même situation qu'en avril dernier
quand les hôpitaux du nord de l'italie
avait été submergé la fédération
nationale des ordres de médecins a
demandé au gouvernement la mise en place
dans confinement total dans tout le pays
l'europe à nouveau épicentre de la
pandémie selon johannes la grèce déjà
confiné impose un couvre feu nocturne à
partir de vendredi l'espagne
passé la barre des quarante mille décès
un seuil déjà franchi par la france il
ya moins d'une semaine place à notre
décryptage avec nos invités pour
analyser la situation du vieux continent
frappé de plein fouet par la deuxième
vague et pour en parler avec nous deux
médecins en direct umberto audio à nimy
vous êtes médecin chirurgien milan en
italie bonsoir merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france philippe emmanueli
vous vous exercez en espagne puisque
vous êtes médecin libéral à barcelone
merci aussi est d'être avec nous en
direct sur notre antenne bienvenue à
vous alors d'abord votre sentiment par
rapport à cette deuxième vague
on l'a dit en france un plus violente
même que la première est ce la même
chose en espagne philippe emmanuelli
quelle est la situation
oui eh bien écoutez ici la situation est
contrastée car c'est vrai que cette
deuxième vague et violente en termes de
contagiosité de contamination on a vu la
courbe des gens contaminés explosé en
revanche la courbe de mortalité est
resté en deçà de la cour de mortalité de
la première vague
donc on al impression qu effectivement
oui la contagiosité est plus importante
que lors de la première vague en
revanche on n'assiste pas aux saturation
des services de réanimation comme on
avait pu le voir très rapidement lors de
la première vague en espagne alors on
italie les choses sont plus compliquées
j'en veux pour preuve ces images de ces
personnes en voiture se faisant oxygénée
devant des hôpitaux à cause du manque de
place elles ont choqué évidemment juste
titre ces images l'épidémie est à
nouveau hors de contrôle ou berton
giovannini et encore des contrôles mais
il faut dire que déjà l'italie c'est une
peu compliqué au niveau de la gestion
centrale parce que chaque région et un
certaine autonomie pour gérer et saint
paul sainte et donc les dix régions qui
sont un peu plus préparé que d autres
magazines blague
un exemple effectivement les régions du
nord dette du nord qui sont aujourd'hui
des nourrissons rouge
mais un peu comme on allume un call et
l'espagne aujourd'hui beaucoup plus des
cas beaucoup plus des malades b d'hôtes
de marque qualité quelques classes et
une capacité des pistes et kehl pour
l'humain reste un corps préserve le dise
ça ce que l'on arrive encore à tester
avec pas trop d'attentes mais chaque
région a le droit a dessiné un peu même
la politique de test donc on a des
régions qu'ils ont accordée les chais de
pouvoir tester beaucoup de monde et
donne aussi la possibilité de faire des
taux d'intérêt
d'autres régions qu'ils ont gardé la
maîtrise du test final publié qui a
apporté à des listes d'attenté dès 10
heures d'attentes pour réaliser ces
tests et en même temps il ya le problème
de la médecine du territoire c'est
qu'ils devaient faire la première filtre
la première barrière et et on peut dire
que ça ça me plait chèque de la première
italienne parce qu'ils n'arrivent pas
trop cher un filtre avant l'arrivée dans
les hôpitaux les problèmes lorsque le
patient arrive et hospitalisé même quand
les symptômes ils pourront maîtriser
il pourrait rentrer chez lui mais il n'y
a pas de moyen de les voir rentrer chez
lui jusqu'à quand ya pas une tante
négatif donc finalement ça te fait le
bouchon dans les hôpitaux parce qu'elle
est les lignes saturées et on n'a pas
renouvelé mon bilan rapide
aujourd'hui je dirais que l'émergence et
ça et à côté mais c'est combien dit mon
confrère galop 6 et qu'il y à tous les
autres pathologies
maintenant qu'ils sont melliger à cause
du vide les équipes ils sont basculées
sur des des hospices creed les médecins
aussi certains services même bascule sur
le tout nouveau vide mais tous les
autres pathologies
il continue à être présent et là c'est
vrai qu'on a des repères d'être la
charge aussi carapace
donc on peut dire en mobilité
accessoires et au fait que tous les
régions sont mineures commises et les
autres mais et les autres m'a dit ils
sont moins traités philippe emmanuelli
on a l'impression d'être dans le même
cauchemar enfin d'ailleurs ce n'est pas
qu'une impression malheureusement que
lors de cette première vague est ce que
vous avez deux sentiments vous qu'en
espagne et je poserai la question après
pour l'italie est ce qu on a tiré les
enseignements
de la première gestion si j'ose dire on
aurait dû faire beaucoup mieux
oui écouter ici quand même on peut dire
qu'on a tiré les enseignements de la
première vague et notamment avec ce
concept de confinement chirurgicale qui
vise à ne plus aller vers un confinement
total et une immobilisation totale de
l'économie
je vous rappelle qu'ici le gouvernement
catalan a décidé de laisser ouvert les
petits commerces ici on peut continuer à
aller dans les librairies on peut aller
continuer aller chez le fleuriste et
avec tous ces petits commerces ouverts
et bien on assiste quand même à une
diminution des contaminations et à une
diminution du fameux taureau et cerise
sur le gâteau aujourd'hui est bien le
gouvernement a promis que si les taux
d'un stick alisation en unité de
réanimation baissé dans sept jours eh
bien il autoriserait la réouverture des
restaurants et des bars même question
berthod giovannini vous pensez comme
philippe emmanuel dis qu'on a quand même
tiré les enseignements même en italie
parce que justement on parlait de cette
décentralisation qui avait pas toujours
été voilà très heureuse ans dans la
gestion de la crise
vous vous seriez aussi indulgent
indigents non je dirais même comme j'ai
déjà eu l'occasion durant une émission
précédente qui est mal heures ce matin à
l'été n'a pas préféré les campagnes de
tonnes lillers et même par rapport à la
première
imp actes qu'on avait commandé mars
effectivement on collait mais les
maladies on simule à maîtriser au niveau
des la thérapie on arrive à mieux les
traiter
donc effectivement on n'est pas dans
l'inconnu mais les eti les équipes
médicales et commencent à être fatigués
ils sont passés de zéro à des gens qui
vont être menacé il ya des mêmes sur des
réseaux tee terre sur des réseaux
facebook des gens qui me know i menace
les médecins et les médecins la cause du
confinement
donc vous voyez maintenant disons que
c'est plus le côté psychologique et là
les pays est en train de craquer alors
qu' aujourd'hui au niveau du point de
vue médical
on connaît mieux
la maladie on sait mieux traiter les
gens en train moindre et à la prise en
charge est effectivement les taux de
mortalité les plus bas encore un endroit
au nombre des gens qui sont malades
contre les nombre des malades des vagues
forcément 91 parce qu'elle plus haut
mais mauvais les confinements c'est une
confinement partiel les écoles restent
ouvertes les commerces ils sont moins
ferme équipe en allemand de mars avril
mai où vraiment tout était bloqué donc
il ya une circulation où il faut dire
quoi ramener ces différents pays des
décédés pas trop un gouffre et les
hôpitaux
mais ils sentent auquel les gens la
possibilité de bouger sauf que là les
noms les numéros et matt est
probablement la semaine prochaine
d'avoir un resserrage la menace de
l'espagne au niveau de la facilité
syrienne commença par les terminaux des
écoles et tous équipés et ralentir la
propagation du virus
une façon de pouvoir déclencher un peu
les hôpitaux mais pour moi les autres
cris de larmes turbie séquelles et
personnel médical et paramédical en
train de craquer donc dans la première
vague ils ont donné beaucoup de soin et
je suis pas sûr que dans la deuxième
bague qu'il soit très très haut de mes
autos on nous parlait de confinement et
des mesures de restriction en italie
philippe herman uli vous avez eu un
confinement très dur aussi en espagne
avec on s'en souvient des enfants qui
n'allait plus à l'école comme en france
et en italie mais qu'ils ne pouvaient
pas du tout sortira ce que vous avez la
crainte et la menace qui s'approche d'un
nouveau confinement également non ici
pas du tout comme je vous disais les
indicateurs laissent au contraire
espérer un assouplissement des mesures
de confinement
puisqu'on parle de réouvrir les bars et
les restaurants ce qui est aujourd'hui
impensable en france ou en italie et
donc non on a l'impression qu'ici il y a
eu un travail de réflexion et d'analysé
par rapport effectivement aux vecteurs
de transmission de l'épidémie selon les
contextes des commerces des petits
commerces des grandes surfaces et on a
l'impression que c'est en train de
marcher alors évidemment il est encore
trop tôt pour en tirer les conclusions
mais pour le moment on ne peut pas dire
que
les mesures de confinement chirurgicale
qui ont été mises en place ne donnent
pas les résultats
et ça c'est intéressant pour les autres
pays d'europe parce que si l'espagne
obtient des résultats en ayant laissé
ouvert les petits commerces en
permettant effectivement aux gens de
circuler de vendre pendant la semaine
parce que je vous le rappelle si en fait
par exemple sur barcelone il ya
effectivement une restriction à la
circulation mais qui ne s'applique en
fait que le week-end en fait en réalité
le vendredi samedi dimanche
mais le reste de la semaine les gens
peuvent circuler librement dans toute la
catalogne donc sur une distance
éventuellement de 250 kilomètres donc on
est très loin effectivement du
confinement périmètre allant france et
aujourd'hui on assiste pas avec ces
mesures à de mauvais résultats
donc on est ici plutôt dans l'espoir de
montrer qu'avec un confinement
intelligent un confinement chirurgicale
eh bien on arrive à la fois à maîtriser
l'épidémie et à préserver l'économie est
essentielle
roberto giovannini c'est vrai que les
petits commerçants en france un qu'on
entendait parler à 20 heures j'en ai eu
trois voilà que c'était vraiment au bord
du désespoir on quand on entend les
propos de philippe emmanuelli voilà on
se dit que ces commerçants français on
vire est le cas et espagnols vous vous
comprenez justement qu'on ferme tous ces
petits commerces
alors n'est ce pas dans à fermer plus
tôt les grands hypermarchés et beaucoup
moins les petits commerces qu'elle
serait ce que le médecin chirurgien
préconiserait is in italy on n'a pas
tout on n'a pas fermé tous les commerces
c'était plutôt le choix du type d'e
commerce qui est elle être fermé est
celui qu'elle est très ouvert donc
l'alimentaire les vêtements pour des
enfants
les librairies les l'électronique qui
sont restés ouverts
par contre à la ferme et les les restes
en ligne les restaurants les bars les
les boutiques de vêtements
on a clairement les musées on
l'affirmait les cinémas tout ce qui
était un peu plus heures voilà ses
membres
lâchez choix l'intrus mais pas sur la
taille mais sous l'éthique du commerce
après on essaie d une telle restriction
au niveau du ventre et dans les
boutiques
moi personnellement je trouve
qu'effectivement l effet de serre mais
les restos c'était plutôt mais aussi
lang ont un impact vous est communiquée
mais c'est plutôt correct parce que
effectivement dans les restos c'était
difficile de garder liste en semant
concerto daleba aussi avec les apéritifs
et tout ça et l'autre côté les gens ils
mettaient les été obligés d'enlever
leurs masques pour être consommés sur
place
donc effectivement là au niveau santé
publique ça pouvoir avoir une certaine
logique de faire ça la grosse discussion
qu'on a aujourd'hui une italie c'est est
ce qu'on va fermer l'école pas et ça ça
va être les compacts c'est les
transports communs aussi ou nantes a
pris la classe politique
il n'a pas prévu à la rentrée une
suffisamment des transports cohabiter
qui les gens soient oubliées dans
l'église de les cram d'un métro donc on
considère que les plus gros merveilleuse
idée c'était les transports publics ou
même et les cons merci en tout cas à
tous les deux bateaux giovannini
philippe-emmanuel et d'avoir témoigné à
la fois de la situation en italie et en
espagne d'avoir été en direct avec nous
sur rt france oat les directions à
présent le brésil est à sud américain
est l'un des plus touchés depuis le
début de la pandémie de kobe 19 le pays
qui a suspendu les essais d'un vaccin
chinois suite à un incident voit son
président tente et de mobilier
remobiliser son peuple à sa façon
grégoire douce et il ne sert à rien de
la fuir de fuir la réalité
nous devons cesser d'être un pays de
paix et des propos fracassants une
volonté de faire face à la pandémie à sa
manière que le président brésilien
jaillir ball sonar au parsèment d'un
certain degré de fatalisme
tout tourne autour de la pandémie il
faut mettre fin à cette affaire
je suis désolé pour les morts je suis
désolé nous allons tous mourir un jour
ici tout le monde va mourir le brésil
vit des heures difficiles et l'espoir
porté par l'hypothèse d'un vaccin
développé par le groupe chinois sinovac
a pris du plomb dans l aile depuis
l'annnonce d'un incident grave
au cours des essais cliniques le bilan
sanitaire depuis le début de la pandémie
fait froid dans le dos le plus grand
pays d'amérique du sud déplore près de
cent soixante trois mille décès liés aux
copies de 19 ce qui en fait le deuxième
état le plus endeuillé sur la planète
pour autant la vie ne s'arrête pas
totalement pour les brésiliens
en témoigne cette fréquentation toujours
élevé de la mythique plage de copacabana
la situation partagent les cariocas
entre crainte et lassitude
c'est encore inquiétant beaucoup de gens
meurent ici
environ mille 500 600 700 personnes par
jour au brésil m et je crois que
maintenant la tendance de la courbe est
à la baisse
elle va automatiquement baisser parce
que les gens sont infectés est
s'immunise et entrave la circulation du
virus sous le problème est que les gens
ne respectent pas les restrictions
imposées par le système de santé
publique du pays
les gens ne porte pas de masque se
rassemblent en masse et tout le monde
est sur la plage sans porter de masque
je pense que nous sommes déjà anesthésié
par la situation nous avons entendu des
mauvaises choses pendant si longtemps
que nous avons fini par nous y habituer
des chiffres peuvent augmenter mais les
gens resteront comme ça
si le tableau est sombre pour les 212
millions de brésiliens
ces derniers peuvent tout de même se
raccrocher à un espoir celui d'une
baisse lente mais certaine du nombre de
décès quotidiens liés au virus
et pour parler du brésil nous sommes
avec hervé théry
géographe professeur à l'université de
sao paulo bonsoir et merci d'être avec
nous la sortie homophobe du président
c'est un dérapage vous répond t-il un
objectif c'est pas le premier il a déjà
plusieurs fois fait des déclarations
fracassantes
je vais pas vous faire le florilège
entier villa d'une fois qu'il aimerait
mieux avoir un fils mort qu'un fils gay
il est coutume et la choisissent tenait
calme depuis quelque temps mais là il
recommence comment perçois que justement
les brésiliens ce type de sortie
le brésil est très divisé un peu comme
les états unis il ya des gens qui sont
indignés mais ils le sont depuis
longtemps et on a d'autres qui trouvent
bien tout ce qui dit quoi qu'il dise on
a reçoit régulièrement par les bobos
whatsapp de ma belle famille des cousins
et des autres qui disent que ce qu'il
dit est très très bien et donc le pays
est partagé je peux pas vous dire si
c'est 60 40 40 60 mais en tout cas il
masse considérable de brésiliens qui le
suivent qui trouve qu'il a raison
de même que les troupes pistes trouvées
très bien tout ce que disait donald
trump effectivement sa cote de
popularité ne semble pas souffrir de ces
sorties ni d'ailleurs de sa position sur
le virus
vous vous l'analysez comment son
élection était un peu un hasard c'est à
dire que la gauche beaucoup de gens
étaient vraiment complètement opposé au
retour 2 du parti des travailleurs de la
gauche donc c'était tout plutôt que le
parti des travailleurs et ça a suffi à
faire 50 % mais obinna c'est n'y a
jamais eu 50 % de gens qu'ils voulaient
vraiment l'appuyer positivement il parmi
les gens qui ont voté pour lui
certains ont déjà considéré qu'ils
avaient fait une erreur qui ne referait
pas mais d'autres s'obstine en disant
non on a eu raison enfin il essaie de se
convaincre mutuellement qu'ils ont bien
fait que c'était le bon choix et que
donc il fallait rester fidèle à ce
président alors vrai toutes les mines
tout ce qui peut faire jaillir molson
avait salué comme une une victoire en
tout cas l'arrêt des essais du vaccin
chinois les ont finalement
repris le président ne minimise pas le
virus il
il le nie carrément est ce qu'on peut
dire ça ils le disent surtout quand il
s'agit de celui qui est développé dans
l'état de sao paulo puisque son le
gouverneur d'état de sang par le
probablement sera son concurrent dans
deux ans et donc tout ce qui peut faire
pour embêter s'opposer à un dogme
ils vont donc là il s'est ouvertement
réjouis que ce vaccin qui est développé
avec les chinois en plus par un institut
de son polo échoue en fait il n'a pas
échoué du tout il ya eu un mort dont il
a été prouvé à peu près pouvez
maintenant en tout cas qui s'est
suicidée donc les probablement les
essais vont reprendre vous avez utilisé
en reprises j'ai parlé dernières
nouvelles mais tout cas c'est un
accident de parcours et ça va devrait
continuer son chemin alors les chiffres
du cor vide ils sont exprimés selon les
experts que sait-on vraiment on parle de
cent soixante deux mille morts au brésil
et quelques 5 6 millions de personnes
contaminées
si ce qu'on estime à partir des cas
déclarés mais comme il ya très peu de
tests on n'en sait rien on est un peu
dans la même situation ont fait le buzz
il est toujours dans la première vague
il n'a pas fini la première et donc il a
2 il a moins de tests qu'il ne faudrait
pas tout à fait assez de masques donc
ils sont plutôt dans notre situation on
était en avril mai et donc il est très
vraisemblable qu'il ya beaucoup de soul
ii soul enregistrements il faut rappeler
que la majorité de la population est
très pauvre il ya beaucoup de mal à
accéder au système de santé public et
donc ils sont pas testés quand ils vont
dans les hôpitaux
c'est souvent qui sont déjà très malade
donc je pense que le nombre des morts
n'est pas sous-estimer le nombre des
gens affectés les probablement
aujourd'hui la situation est toujours la
même pas d'évolution en tout cas dans
les mesures de restriction comment les
choses se passe concrètement sur le
terrain au brésil parce qu'on sait que
les gouverneurs notamment joué un rôle
important dans chaque région où il faut
rappeler que le brésil c'est 15 fois la
france et que c'est un état fédéral donc
chaque état une politique se séparer
comme on vient de le voir aux états unis
donc ça dépend beaucoup de chaque
gouverneur et même de chaque mère dont
il ya des endroits où c'est très strict
et très respecté il y en a d'autres où
ça ne l'est pas du tout il y en a où il
ya des mesures de façade prises et les
gens font ce qu'ils veulent c'est ce
qu'on a à l'écran ce moment les cas des
os cassés les habitants de rio sont
vraiment pas très disciplinés ils
veulent aller à la plage et donc on a
des situations extrêmement contrastées
mais en tout cas on a pu observer six
mois un peu mon travail de jéhovah
l'expansion de la maladie de l'internet
dans tout le pays
il n'y a pratiquement plus haut plus est
peu plausible qu'il ait pas eu de cas
ils n'ont pas tous des morts ce que les
gens souvent sont transférées dans les
hôpitaux des grandes villes pour mourir
mais ça atteint tout le pays y compris
la masoni y compris le pantanal y
compris des régions très basse densité
merci avait atterri à géographe
professeur à l'université de sao paulo
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur arte
france et le point pour terminer sur ce
chapitre du corps d'un virus en france
les derniers chiffres de la crise santé
publique france dénombre 35 mille huit
cent soixante dix neuf nouveaux cas de
contamination au bide en 24 heures 329
personnes sont décédées à l'hôpital et
351 patients admis en réanimation le
taux de positivité des tests s'établit
désormais à 19,5 pour cent les nouveaux
décès porte le bilan total des morts dus
qu'aux vide en france à 42 1536 rester
avec nous dans quelques instants nous
parlerons du contournement de l'accord
avec l'union européenne boris johnson
essuie un refus de la part des lords qui
ont retoqué certaines dispositions et
s'aligne ainsi sur bruxelles puis
direction la syrie où se déroule la
conférence internationale sur le retour
des réfugiés organisé par moscou à damas
l'organisation des nations unies
participent en tant qu'observateur
[Musique]
oui
comment on peut expliquer qu'elle un
groupe énorme comme areva qui est
spécialisé puisse acheter des mines
inexploitables
ce n'est pas explicable mais ça permet
d'envoyer aussi des gratifications on va
dire et à des politiciens nigérien la
gestion fantaisiste d'areva a des
répercussions incroyable jusqu'au
président américain obama donne son
accord pour qu'areva bénéficie d'un prêt
de 2 milliards de dollars alors que
l'agent ce qui est censé gérer ces prêts
un avis négatif
je ne suis pas pour ou contre le
nucléaire je suis simplement pour une
industrie sans corruption parce que
cette industrie là si elle crée un
incident c'est pour l'éternité
[Musique]
une part de l'afrique comme d'un
continent en perpétuelle de son
dysfonctionnement actuel tient à
l'absence de redistribution à la
population par des dirigeants qui ont
une fâcheuse tendance à tout garder pour
les pays occidentaux ont favorisé cette
dérive en encourageant le maintien au
pouvoir de politiciens de plus en plus
âgés pour assurer la stabilité des pays
et des sourires
elles ont eu la prétention de croire que
les valeurs qu'elle défend des est
imposé par la force dans leur conquête
était universel dans cette terre des
possibles où s'esquissent les figures du
monde à venir
il faut changer notre logiciel et
arrêtez de dénigrer le faire à
l'africaine en octroyant au management à
l'anglo-saxonne
[Musique]
le nombre de contaminés au point de
chaque semaine je pense que le système
des chu est à bout de souffle
si on ne réforme pas dans les prochaines
années les sièges sûrs on va continuer
notre des plates le gouvernement ait
finalement pris entre deux feux il
s'agit là d'éviter une crise économique
et en même temps d'hésiter à la
propagation du virus à jour et pas être
à la place du gouvernement français en
ce moment car hier que des mauvaises
solutions
ce que des gens comme moi propose en ce
moment c'est que à la fin du confinement
on teste 60 millions de français
si on continue comme on fait là moi j'ai
un peu peur pour décoincer jusqu'à la
fin janvier
[Musique]
21h30 heure française merci de nous
rejoindre en direct sur rt france à une
cinquantaine de jours du break site
l'inquiétude des ordis truelle français
ces derniers voient d'un très mauvais
oeil les importations américaines en
europe qui pourraient transiter via la
grande bretagne en cause des produits
américains dont l'exigence en termes de
normes sanitaires est bien moindre qu'en
france et celle fage poulets au chlore
deux hormones risque-t-on de se
retrouver avec ses mais peu ragoûtant
dans nos assiettes
oui à en croire certaines organisations
françaises du monde agricole et
agroalimentaire dans un communiqué
conjoint la fnsea la coopération
agricole et l'association des industries
de l'agroalimentaire interpelle les
pouvoirs publics sur cette menace post
briques site
si la secrétaire d'état britannique au
commerce international
madame strauss accepte d'importer des
produits américains aux normes
sanitaires inférieur au nôtre comme le
poulet au chlore et le boeuf aux
hormones les produits agroalimentaires
qui entrent sur le marché européen
devront respecter l'ensemble des normes
de production européenne car aujourd'hui
l'union européenne limite voire interdit
l'importation de certains produits
américains qui ne respectent pas les
normes sanitaires en vigueur
après le break site les britanniques eux
pourraient conclure un accord de libre
échange avec les états unis
du pain béni pour le pays de l'oncle sam
qui pourrait donc exporter ses produits
vers le royaume-uni produits qui
pourraient se retrouver ensuite sur le
marché européen grâce aux accords entre
londres et bruxelles
une pénétration du marché de l'ue eux
qui pourrait comporter des risques
sanitaires c'est en tout cas ce que
révèle ce rapport d'une ong britannique
le système alimentaire britannique est
fragile et vulnérable aux perturbations
mais il dépend également fortement de
ceux de ses voisins de l'union
européenne un retrait sans accord
pourrait nuire à la santé publique à la
protection des consommateurs au bien
être animal et à la durabilité
environnementale car d'autres pays
commencent à produire des aliments pour
le royaume
afin de remplacer les importations en
provenance de l'union européenne
toujours est il que les trois
organisations françaises exhorte donc
les pouvoirs publics à tout faire pour
parvenir à un accord car comme le
rappelle le communiqué en termes de
commerce agricole et alimentaire la
france est le troisième fournisseur est
le deuxième client du royaume uni afin
de prévenir de possibles distorsions de
concurrence nous exhortons les
négociateurs à tout faire pour
s'accorder sur un futur accord
commercial qui soutiennent les
exploitations agricoles les entreprises
et l'emploi et contribue à protéger les
flux commerciaux entre la france et le
royaume uni la ligne rouge européenne du
maintien des règles du jeu équitables
entre lui et le royaume uni et le
respect de l'intégrité du marché unique
ne peut être franchie un nouveau
paramètre pourrait permettre de vaincre
l'inquiétude du monde agricole et
agroalimentaire français la récente
élection de joe biden à la maison
blanche
pas sûr que ce dernier adopte la même
ligne que donald trump dans ses
relations commerciales avec le
royaume-uni poste briques site londres
aura peut-être alors la possibilité de
ne pas abaisser ses normes sanitaires et
éviter ainsi le boeuf aux hormones
de quoi réjouir les palets français même
les moins difficiles les négociations
sur le break site qui s'enlise en tout
cas la chambre des lords n'est pas
d'accord et elle le fait savoir à boris
johnson
lundi soir la chambre haute du parlement
a retoqué certaines dispositions du
projet de loi du gouvernement lui
permettant de contourner ses obligations
vis-à-vis de l'union européenne dans du
même coup il s'aligne sur la position de
bruxelles alors que des discussions
commerciales ont repris il ne reste que
quelques jours à londres et l'union
européenne pour s'accorder la mi
novembre étant considéré comme une date
butoir afin de pouvoir ratifier attend
un accord qui entrerait en vigueur le
1er janvier 2021 et pour en parler nous
sommes en direct avec claude
blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir closer
l'horizon merci d'être avec nous alors
le refus de la chambre des lords
est ce que c'est vraiment un affront
pour le premier ministre britannique
howie sais c'est un affront puisque les
dealers dans leur sagesse 10 au premier
ministre conservateur britannique qu' il
n'est sans doute pas au courant que doit
respecter les traités internationaux et
notamment le traité qu'il assignait sur
le bref il y a un an
or le projet de loi qu'il a soumis la
chambre dès lors est bien contrôlée
contrevient contredit sur au moins un
point très important au traité qui a été
signé l'année dernière et ce point très
important puisque c'est la liberté
totale de circulation sans frontières
entre les deux irlande alors c'est aussi
un revers parce que la position de la
chambre d alors affaibli la position de
boris johnson vis-à-vis de l'union
européenne dans la négociation qui est
en cours
d'abord l'union européenne a déjà formé
un recours contre le projet de loi
puisque boris johnson refuse de le
modifier
et puis ensuite le ministre des affaires
étrangères d'irlande a dit ouh yeah ce
que beaucoup de gens pensent tout bas à
savoir à quoi bon à quoi bon négocier un
nouveau traité sur le futur régime
si le toute façon gouvernement
britannique ne respectent pas le traité
signé l'année dernière donc on en est là
crise de confiance en réalité très
importante entre la grande bretagne et
l'union européenne
alors claude que veut vraiment obtenir
boris johnson dans ces négociations
oh bah c'est assez simple dans les zones
sonne il veut obtenir le libre échange
entre la grande bretagne et l'union
européenne avec les inconvénients que
votre sujet vient de démontrer parce que
ce qu'il veut c'est un lieu de libre
échange inconditionnel un libre échange
à l'ancienne comme dans les années 50
or ce que veut l'union européenne c'est
s'il ya un libre-échange évidemment que
ce soit dans des conditions de
concurrence équitables et que les normes
du marché européen soit respectée
puisque d'ailleurs les britanniques les
respecte on voit pas pourquoi il se
permettrait dans les années à venir de
baisser le niveau d'exigence en matière
environnementale soit en matière sociale
soit même en ce qui concerne les
subventions mais pour le moment les
britanniques refusent de s'engager dans
cette voie
ils veulent être totalement libre de
modifier leur législation interne comme
ils l'entendent
le l'autre point c'est que l'union
européenne dit abhorrer johnson de toute
façon une fois qu'on sera mis d'accord
sur le respect des normes européennes
eh bien il faut bien comprendre que
l'accès à ce marché très très très grand
très important suppose une contrepartie
qui nous paraissent bien normal c'est
que nos pêcheurs puissent continuer à
accéder aux zones de pêche
traditionnelle dans les eaux
britanniques d'ailleurs l'épaisseur
accès dans les mêmes conditions aux eaux
des pays membres de l'union européenne
et la blu ray johnson dit pas question
souveraineté britannique
nous négocierons par exemple chaque
année ou tous les deux ans que les trois
ans et faisons comme je viens de le
faire avec la norvège pays extérieurs à
l'union européenne un accord de deux ans
donc très précaires et pour lequel on
négocie chaque année les quotas de pêche
pour chaque espèce halieutiques pour
chaque espèce de poisson dont on est
bien loin d'un accord et effectivement
ben on va voir ce qui va se passer dans
les prochains jours
mais justement que blanchemaison vous
dites on est bien loin d'un accord à ce
que l'échec des discussions devient de
plus en plus inéluctable selon vous ai
googlés wee aa dérouler les arguments
que je viens d'avancé l'échec est
relativement probable
cela dit cela dit la plupart des
décideurs économiques et politiques dans
les grandes capitales européennes à
londres comme à paris comme à berlin et
ailleurs
sans tout à fait conscient de l'énorme
désordres économiques et administratifs
qui s'installera à partir du mois de
janvier
s'il n'y a pas d'accord ça veut dire des
milliers de camions qui font la queue
dans la région de calais et dans la dans
le comté du kent en grande bretagne en
attendant que les formalités douanières
soit fait ça veut dire peut-être des
difficultés d'approvisionnement
agroalimentaire notamment aux fruits et
légumes mais aussi en médicaments aux
grands en royaume uni grande bretagne ça
veut dire aussi des désordres sociaux
dans les ports dans les ports grand de
grande bretagne comme dans les ports
français ça veut dire aussi sans doute
le risque de difficultés politiques
importantes entre l'irlande du nord et
le gouvernement britannique et des
risques aussi de renaissance des
conflits qu'il y a eu malheureusement
pendant très longtemps entre la
république d'irlande et le gouvernement
britannique
donc les enjeux sont considérables alors
il se peut tout à fait que prenant
conscience de cela la semaine prochaine
eh bien les dirigeants des pays
européens et et boris johnson se
reprennent et qu'ils consacrent quelques
jours à négocier un accord ce qui est
possible s'il ya une prise de conscience
aujourd'hui le sujet n'est pas sous les
feux de l'actualité
personne n'en parle par conséquent il
n'y a pas de pression politique
et quand il n'y a pas de pression
politique et n'est possible les
négociations entre l'union européenne et
un pays tiers fusse-t-il là la grande
bretagne n'avance pas
donc actuellement si la situation reste
ce qu'elle est eh bien il n'y aura pas
d'accord s'il ya une prise de conscience
de l'aspect dramatique de la situation
il peut y avoir un accord à la fin de la
semaine prochaine mais au niveau des
chefs d'état de gouvernement
en tout cas un boris johnson
doit se passer en ce moment du soutien
sans doute précieux d'un certain donald
trump occupé par d'autres petits soucis
que je vais y donne devrait logiquement
être le nouveau président des états unis
à partir du 20 janvier 2021
quelles conséquences selon vous pour ces
briques site pour boris johnson
notamment brigitte elle n'a pas de
chance parce que d'ailleurs by day by
day 'n' il ya un énorme le bi irlandais
aux états unis et ce lobby hollande elle
est très présent au sénat d'ailleurs joe
biden en fait partie et effectivement
c'est le b irlandais par la voix de joe
biden a fait savoir ou acceptant que il
n'était absolument pas acceptable que
l'on prenne le risque avec un accord mal
ficelé ou pas d'accord du tout dada
d'une renaissance des troubles en
irlande du nord et joe biden a dit très
clairement que si c'était le cas il
n'était pas question qu'il ya un accord
de libre échange entre les états unis et
le royaume uni qu'en bretagne ce qui
résoudrait la sphère des producteurs de
poulet dont vous avez parlé tout à
l'heure
merci beaucoup au club blanchemaison
expert en relations internationales
d'avoir été avec nous en direct elle sur
rt france conférence aujourd'hui à damas
sur le retour des réfugiés le retour des
exilés perçue comme une nécessité pour
reconstruire le pays selon bachar
el-assad beaucoup d'enjeu pour cette
réunion donc soutenu par la russie l'onu
est présente en tant qu'observateur pour
la première fois depuis le début de la
guerre en mars 2011 et le liban il sera
représenté par son ministre des affaires
sociales et nous faisons le point depuis
damas avec notre correspondant antoine
claireaux plus de cinq millions et demi
de syriens ont fui leur pays depuis le
début des hostilités il ya maintenant
près de dix ans et maintenant le
gouvernement syrien justement à l'aide
de ce genre d'initiative cherche à les
faire revenir mais voilà les obstacles
sont nombreux les infrastructures sont
détruites ou alors en mauvais état les
sanctions internationales contre la
syrie les pénalise fortement la
situation humanitaire et sécuritaire
peut parfois être délicate dans
certaines régions et puis sans même
parler de duca de l'enclavé d'idleb
toujours sous contrôle terroristes dans
son message d'ouverture de cette
conférence sergueï lavrov a dénoncé le
double jeu d'un groupe de pays menés par
les états unis en ne venant pas ne
participant pas à cette conférence de
damas les difficultés sont donc variées
et nombreuses et l'ambition de cette
conférence est justement de trouver des
solutions je vous propose d'écouter à ce
sujet l'intervention d'un conseiller du
gouvernement syrien pour la syrie où
vous l'état syrien en tant que
gouvernement l'important c'est assurer
ses infrastructures au moins au minimum
de conditions pour que celle établissent
une fois le processus est déclenché on
voit là la reconstruction du pays et le
retour de ces réfugiés dans les régions
de la syrie pas seulement dans les
banlieues de damas où dalip dans les
différentes régions sur la géographie de
la syrie est importante
assurer le l'électricité le téléphone
les logements etc tous à tous ces
problèmes les conditions initiales pour
le retour pose le problème majeur c'est
le relever les sanctions sur la syrie
les sanctions au niveau économique je
parle pour leur retour dans les bonnes
conditions c'est à dire rétablir la
réaction du monde des technologies
elle est à lire les routes les écoles
les hôpitaux etc
c'est il faut les réhabiliter ces
infrastructures
cette conférence justement être
organisée par les autorités syriennes
avec l'appui le soutien de la russie et
la participation de 18 pays dont par
exemple le liban voisin qui à lui seul
accueille près d'un million et demi de
réfugiés syriens l'onu et la croix-rouge
sont également présents à cette
conférence en tant qu'observateur
contrairement à l'union européenne
pourtant invité mais qui a décliné cette
invitation estimant que les conditions
d'un retour des réfugiés ne sont pas
réunies à l'heure actuelle l'objectif de
cette conférence est pourtant louable
tenter de surmonter les obstacles qui
empêchent à l'heure actuelle les syriens
de revenir sur leur terre natale et pour
en parler nous sommes avec un gérard un
vestiaire analyses politiques
géopolitiques chercheur associé à la
fondation d'études pour le moyen-orient
bonsoir gérard westermann
on direct sur rt france la communauté
internationale qui d'abord qui boudent
cette conférence
ce n'est pas une surprise effectivement
la situation à telle que vous la
décrivez elle est en trois volets n'est
ce pas il ya un volet a effectivement
humanitaires sociales si je puis dire
il ya un volet économique et un
troisième volet politique le retour des
réfugiés ne peut se faire qu'à partir du
moment où il y a un retour que vient
d'être expliqué à l'état acceptable des
infrastructures mais pas seulement mais
de la vie économique du pays donc il
faut des investissements
or les investissements ils ne peuvent
pas être assurée seulement par la russie
il faut qu'ils soient assurés par les
pays arabes il faut qu'il soit assuré
par l'union européenne il faut qu'ils
soient assurés par les états unis
or ces investissements là nous pourrons
être faite que dans le cadre d'un
règlement politique
troisième volet est donc il ya un
certain nombre d'investisseurs possible
qui souhaitent le départ d'appel de de
bachar el-assad de bachar el-assad donc
vous voyez vous c'est un dossier
effectivement très compliqué le retour
des réfugiés nécessite des
investissements mais les investissements
doivent passer par une évolution de la
situation politique a comme l'a dit
d'ailleurs vladimir poutine il faut que
toutes les troupes étrangères quittent
la syrie et comme l'a ajoutée a ensuite
avec 140e le lendemain l'iran y compris
d'envoyer où la situation est loin des 5
alors quand on dit quand l'union
européenne des crimes réunion prématurée
est ce qu'on peut vraiment s'exprimer en
ces termes elle est vraiment prématuré
selon vous cette réunion au nom des
trois volets que je vienne présenter
effectivement il faut oublier des
avancées sur le volet politique pour que
ensuite il puisse y avoir des avancées
sur le volet économique et que dans ces
conditions le plus grand nombre possible
de réfugiés puissent revenir dans leur
pays
alors en attendant ce sont les
populations qui payent
le prix la situation est extrêmement
compliquée sur le plan économique en
syrie le régime a sa part de
responsabilité n'est ce pas je crois que
les 380 mille morts et les 5 millions de
personnes qui ont fui leur pays à son
doivent être assumés par le régime de
bachar el-assad dont quitte ce n'est pas
ce ne sont pas les pays extérieurs qui
doivent assumer la totalité de la
responsabilité politique
vous dites une transition politique et
laisser faire on l'a on l'a bien compris
aujourd'hui quelles sont les conditions
à réunir pour cette transition politique
précisément il faut qu'il ya une
acceptation à 2 par moscou a
effectivement de trouver un moyen
élégant que bachar el-assad puisse
quitter le pouvoir
à partir de ce moment là je crois qu'il
ira à une ouverture politique importante
et que l'ensemble du mécanisme dont on
vient par eux dont je viens de parler en
trois volets pour a assez rapidement se
mettre en place
au coeur de cette reconstruction
évidemment c'est tout l'enjeu le retour
des exilés quelles garanties selon vous
offrir pour permettre ce retour en
sécurité
le retour en sécurité c'est la mise en
place donc de ces trois volets si il y
avait le départ de bachar el-assad
il y aurait la possibilité dans un temps
relativement rapide de débloquer
quelques dizaines de milliards sachant
que la reconstruction globale de la
syrie est estimé entre 80 à 100
milliards de francs que ce sont des
sommes tout à fait conséquente
d'où la nécessité que la communauté
internationale y participent et que les
desiderata de cette communauté puisse
s'exprimer et être concrétisé à savoir
l'évolution du pouvoir merci gérard
vsphere analyste géopolitique chercheur
associé à la fondation d'études pour le
moyen-orient merci d'avoir été
avec nous deux jours après l'entrée en
vigueur d'un cessez-le-feu total dans le
haut karabagh la capitulation du premier
ministre nikol pashinian est plutôt mal
acceptée en arménie un accord ou de
trahison dont les arméniens quentin
mauclair un accord qui passe mal en
arménie après la conclusion d'un cessez
le feu total pour le conflit du haut
karabagh une nouvelle manifestation
massive a éclaté ce mercredi sur la
place de la liberté dans le centre de la
capitale erevan
ils étaient plusieurs milliers à braver
l'interdiction des autorités pour
dénoncer le compromis mettant fin aux
hostilités au coeur de la controverse
le premier ministre nikol pashinian a
défendu son acte de reddition des
remparts en effet si les hostilités
avaient continué il y avait une très
forte probabilité que c'était pana kert
carte martouni marc tongs et aspirant à
ce qu'elle soit capturée et après cela
nos deuxième troisième quatrième
cinquième et sixième zone défensive se
serait retrouvée sous blocus et des
milliers de nos soldats se serait
également retrouvé sous un blocus
la police a effectué des dizaines
d'arrestations en début de rassemblement
notamment des militants et responsables
du parti arménie prospère
les manifestants se sont ensuite dirigés
vers le parlement et le siège du
gouvernement
contrairement à la nuit de dimanche à
lundi où il avait pu envahir ces deux
lieux stratégiques
les contestataires se sont heurtés à un
important dispositif policier ce
mercredi une revendication commune
ressortait de la foule en colère
la démission du premier
ministre nikol pashinian coupable à
leurs yeux d'un acte de trahison en
capitulant devant les azéri aujourd'hui
nous sommes réunis ici pour exprimer
notre opinion en tant qu arménien en
tant que peuple arménien et pour exiger
la démission de nikol pashinian il a
trahi sa patrie son peuple il n'est pas
légitime pour gouverner comme premier
ministre je suis venu demander la
démission de nikol pashinian car
quelqu'un ne peut pas résoudre le
problème de tout un peuple sans
consulter personne sans rien demander à
personne en particulier aux gens qui
l'ont élu
je demande la démission immédiate de
nikol pashinian entré en vigueur mardi à
minuit cet accord de paix a été élaboré
sous l'égide de la russie ce mercredi
des premières forces de maintien de la
paix russes sont arrivés dans la région
du haut karabagh ce cessez-le-feu met
fin à six semaines de conflit qui auront
provoqué selon un premier décompte
partiel
la mort de quelques 1500 personnes c'est
la fin de cette émission on se retrouve
dans quelques minutes à 22 heures pour
un point complet sur l'actualité du jour
et
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous